-I wanted to ask you
this question
because it's a it
has a funny ending.
We were talking backstage.
I was going to say,
"Hey, I heard that you change
your phone number a lot."
-Yeah, I do.
-Right.
You do.
Me, I used to too.
-I change it so often.
-I used to do it.
-Before, I used to do it a lot.
-Because too many people
just get your number
and start calling you.
Is that why?
-No, because I didn't answer
the -- the -- the messages.
And then I realized, you know,
that I wanted to focus,
be in the studio, work,
and I wanted to focus.
-Oh, yeah. Me too.
I wanted to focus, too.
Yeah, I wanted to focus on work.
That's why I changed my number.
Yeah.
-No, I mean it.
And then I was like,
okay, mira,
I'd rather not
change the phone.
Fresh start.
-Yeah.
-You know.
-And then what happens
is you --
you change your number,
but then people text because
someone else gets that number,
and then your friends
start texting that number,
not knowing that
you changed yours.
-That happened to you?
'Cause that happened to me.
-Yeah. It does.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean it.
That happened to me.
Like literally, I realized
because I didn't know
that that happened.
I thought that when you use
a phone number,
then the phone number,
you know,
like it disappears or something.
I don't know why I thought it.
But they --
-Yeah, they should happen.
They should like --
-It should happen, no?
-At least wait
a couple of years and --
-It was your number.
-If it's your number,
at least wait...
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
If it's your number, you ea--
-[ Laughs ]
-I mean, I'm moto papi.
I don't mess around.
I go if you want to --
[Laughter]
-You want to take my number.
If I change it,
it should be --
-Period.
-Out for at least ten years.
-But that doesn't happen.
-No.
-And then I realized that
people, my friends that,
uh, thought that
they were texting me,
they were texting random people.
-But that happened to you for
a friend that we know as well.
That's been on our show --
Harry Styles.
-Yeah. That happened.
[ Laughs ]
[ Audience cheers ]
-So what?
-You have to tell me this.
-That happened.
-So talk to me.
So Harry texted you.
-I have proof.
Like, it happened.
-You have proof?
Do you -- Like what?
Do you have a photo?
What do you have with me?
-Bear with me.
[ Laughter ]
I literally have proof.
-Where...?
-Bear with me. Bear with me.
-Yeah. No. No problem.
-Okay.
-What are you doing?
Wait.
-So...
-You had your phone
in your boot?
[ Laughter ]
-I do. Yeah.
-That's where you keep
your phone?
That's so cool.
I'm gonna start doing that, too.
Are you kidding me?
I'm gonna totally keep my --
-Mira, mira,
I'm moto mami.
Even moto mami needs to keep
the phone in the boot.
She keeps it in the boot.
If the -- If the purse
didn't match the outfit,
it's like in the boot.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
-It's in the boot, man. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-All right, so you --
You want --
-You want to see?
-I really do.
This is a real...
Now how did you end up
with this?
So.
-Okay.
-I'm gonna.
So Harry styles texts you
thinking it's you, but it's not.
Someone else
has the phone number.
-Yeah.
-And this is real.
-Look, look. Okay, look.
Okay.
-All right. Let me.
-Okay.
-All right.
So --
-Can you believe he thought --
-Which one --
Which one is he?
-He sent me this screenshot.
Okay. In the DMs.
In the Instagram DMs?
-Yeah.
-Saying your texts
are confusing.
-That was Harry that said,
"This is so beautiful"?
-Yeah. He said that
because he was like,
oh, I like -- I love this song
that is called [Indistinct].
-Yes.
-He sent me this screenshot.
And he was like,
"This is beautiful."
-And then and you wrote back
or supposedly you wrote back.
-And it wasn't me.
The -- The --
-"I know my darling."
-The random person said,
"Yeah, I know, my darling."
-And then he says,
[As Harry Styles] "Love it."
-And then he says...
[ Laughter ]
..."Love you."
[ Laughs ]
-[ Normal voice ]
Love you.
And then Harry says,
[As Harry Styles]
"I love you, too."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
With lots of O's.
Very romantic Harry.
And then this person writes.
-The person says,
"Haha, sorry you're wrong.
I don't know who you are."
-And then --
And then Harry writes back.
"I'm confused."
[ Laughter ]
And then the person puts --
-The person, oh my God.
The person says,
"This number
belongs to someone before.
But now it's my number,
so don't bother me anymore.
Good night."
Thank you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
-To Harry...
[ Laughs ]
[ Sighs ]
-Imagine, imagine --
-To Harry Styles.
-Imagine being that person now
looking to Jimmy Fallon show
and say, "I said don't bother me
anymore to Harry Styles."
[ Laughter ]
-Harry just turned up
in your DM and be like,
"Hey, what's going on with you?"
-So he said, these --
these texts are confusing.
Your texts are confusing.
He said something like that.
And I was like,
what does he mean?
-That's an old number.
Oh, my God.
And then I realized
that is the best thing ever.
No.
All right, save it.
Protect it in your boot.
Uh, forever. Um.